[music]
goo
invincible You should be dumb too
Tidus seems to have fallen 8
hurdles am yeah yeah
me
ah ah
rar
[music]
[applause]
guest guest me
guest It's
morning
goo
all
Hello,
come down early for breakfast.  I can't fight
oops,
love girl, take a
seat.
Can you tell me what kind of
diet you've been on until now
? Liquid diet, intravenous fluids,
etc. Ugh.
I
wonder if I can eat it all
, but there are a lot of
goods
.
Even if it
was supposed to be set to be
terrifying, Video Stark Hey,
I think it was busier when I came to see
you,
but when it was bustling, that was
more than 200 years ago.
It's been a
long time since I've been starred
Gel amazing
What a combination of the castle country and the green country The
name of the country is here in my village, not in Italia Dale.
Do
n't you know,
eh, yeah,
it was a special thing, and in the
past, the seven countries fought over and over again, and
it was so funny.  And
then, because of the ugly conflict, God
chose a leader from among the people, and those people
struggled to unite the nation into three nations, and that's how it is now
.  I don't like the setting of the
world, but even if it's more than 200 years after the time I was playing,
I guess I'll ask if I've been here that long ago,
but only once saas
Hey,
I'm on the rail, this kid was lit,
and I'm going to say "k".
If you have 4 large sums of money, you can stay at an inn like this for 10 nights
.
Think of it as your home and take it
easy It's not going to end, so it's not going to end well
Well then
Name system level 1100 Race High Elf
Noon Skill master number 3
hasn't changed
It's
too
much of a cheat After
that, the illuminance meter is
charged Yes, of course, it's because you
're here.  Disconnected from the master system and the
hospital's system
, I guess there was a power outage after going to bed
.  Hey,
come on,
there should be other players on this continent,
right?
I wonder how
everyone is doing.
add some
rar
It's
just a weapon It's just a light spot It's okay
Tebit Yoshikoshi sees magic for the
first time
I wonder if it's rare for a normal villager to have a lot of magical seals
Big is going to put on a lantern
It
was  It
's time for dinner, so
me ah ah ah
um
[music]
I'm sorry for being so noisy Hey
, there's no one who's going to be particularly harmful, so don't worry about
it.  That's right, it
doesn't look like a rock-paper-scissors,
but it's soft This is the best
hard jaguar in the village
.  You
're blowing coke, you're
going to end up with the
food you
've been working on.
It
's a silver head, but it's a silver head, but
you can stop
it in a
terrifying place.
There's an established theory that the witch of the seal is a bath
bus.Hey, you're
okay, you're fine
.
It's a dark history of parking other players who are too big at the waves
But the
fact that Mr. Ueki is still alive means that other players
still exist.
Ah,
yes, what should I do if I
wake up
?
Memorial Service and Judgment
Delete Log
[Music]
Ah,
pull,
increase,
garter,
lie, are
you really going to go with that look?
I'm
worried about Klaelf.
There are monsters in Mouri, and even he has a decent
amount of skill, so don't worry
.
Reit-chan, I
'll be looking for souvenirs, so please look forward to it
.
There's no one
here The ring of the latter and the
fraction that can reach the head of the base with this The
thing that protects men The world entrusted to me is
chaos Please save me
[music] I
'm relaxing with David
I got it in, but I wonder
if the keyword didn't work out
somehow.  A rare record
While I'm away It
's okay if you can get through the ordeal of your head and come here
Hey,
peace, peace, system, etc.
About 60 years ago, I
want to get in touch with my husband.  I was talking about
arm, but the master ignored the merits of the defense side
[music]
Well, I can't let go of my hand.
I don't really understand
, the guy after Skull came
.
Jerry-dan
Peace
Who is the child from Ness
? Oh master's son, right?
Ah
To put it simply,
you can make a brain player character by doing your household budget. It's already a convenient system day to earn money in the game.
Hey, I wonder if everyone is doing
well I haven't dated anyone yet, and I've never dated 3 of them, but
compared to 3 people who are over 100 years old,
I don't know what to say in the fall.
Well, what are you waiting for?
He
was saying something like that he became Stan
.
Half of
your husband's companions were humans, is
n't
it?
Let's
keep playing this
way for 200
years.
Apparently, if you have time, could you please take a look?
Get to the village and
come to the
distorted stone house
.
It's true,
but Hosoe
[music]
Is it
me jab?
Thank you.
I would be happy if you could read it over there instead of
Chan.  I was supposed to have gone to the hospital, but it
was really dry to defeat this bear and come back.
I've
lived for over 200 years
, so I
'm not
going to get into it.
Let's put on a good throw Encounter [music]
Chester  an
[music]
I'm strong with bears when I'm gay,
but I'm weak with alcohol
n
original 6 a 9
e
[music]
c
ano
ne
good good good
[music]
[applause]
I have
is good
[music]
ana
ni
amenonakani
[music]
me
dj it's
cheap
al